black panther wakanda forever's run time  has reportedly been revealed via listing  through some movie theater chains and  it's coming in at a whopping two hours  and 41 minutes that is not the longest  of run time for an MCU film but  certainly it's it it's up there it's up  there and I think that's for the better  I mean how many times have we heard  people complain about oh this MCU movie  feels way too rushed or should have been  longer should have been expanded upon  and when you see the trailer for Black  Panther wakanda forever when you know  everything they've had to deal with with  production problems some real life  tragedies the story they have to tell  with introducing Namor and then also  dealing with the passing of t'challa  Chadwick Boseman there's so much story  to tell that I'm glad that a movie that  is going to need this much dramatic heft  Breathing Room gravitas to give them a  run time like this I hope this is true  because if so good on them